( whirring )
( window opening )
Shuttle Pilot: Might want to
take a step back, Captain!
Oh, by the way, I'm a huge fan.
- Closing blast shields.
- No, no! NO-- aah!
Shuttle Marmota,
you are cleared to dock.
( laughs )
What an idiot!
Boom! We're here.
You like bratwurst?
My uncle has bratwurst,
like, a restaurant.
I was thinking maybe you and me,
we could go
grab a couple of brewskis
and pop out there.
Welcome aboard
the Invincible II.
Glad to have you here.
Took you long enough.
Let me give you the grand tour
before we embark.
( glitching )
This is my pride and joy.
My baby.
( distorted )
A baby always remembers
its father.
( distorted echoes )
Father, father, father...
First stop, the--
the heart and soul of the--
I've yet to meet a problem that
can't be solved with explosives.
And speaking of explosives--
( distorted chatter )
All will be consumed by
darkness.
( slowed )
Hi, Captain!
Celci:
Where are you going, Captain?
Ms. Whitacre: Do you think she
had  the right idea, Captain?
Did she give up
or did she move on?
All a matter
of perspective, I suppose.
( echoing laughter )
Come on, slowpoke.
( overlapping echoes )
( echoes continue )
All that's left now...
...is for you to say the word.
Try not to get them
too excited, Captain.
I know how your speeches
can get people riled up.
( laughing, grunting )
Captain, why does
this seem familiar?
Eh? Aah!
( music playing )
Narrator:
And so our intrepid Captain
falls headlong
into the spiraling chaos
of dimensional calamity,
heralding the beginning
of the end.
My goodness,
what an adventure.
I swear, this story
never ceases to amaze me.
By the way,
it's good to see you again.
Or for the first time,
depending on your past choices.
Either way,
I'm sure we'll meet again
for the first time
in the very near future
and/or somewhat distant past.
Should this not prove
to be the end of all reality,
which it almost certainly is,
it would be my great pleasure
to guide you
through my own universe
should the opportunity arise.
Which doesn't seem likely
to happen at this juncture,
but when thinking
in infinites,
unlikely is just certainty
waiting for its turn.
- ( running footsteps )
- ( knocking on door )
What's wrong, sport?
Bless my stars,
was it the nightmare
about the spaceship again?
That one just keeps coming back,
doesn't it?
Well, I know just the thing
that's going to cure that--
another story.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
Ugh, maybe
a little too grisly.
Uh, read that one
too many times.
Nah.
Not in the mood.
Eh, not today.
Why don't you decide, huh?
You could read
a nice romance story.
That'd be fun.
Or a horror story.
I know how much
you love scary stories.
But it might give you
a few more nightmares,
so you could go romance.
It'll be a little silly
and more than a little sappy,
but it might be just the thing
to kick you right back to sleep.
Well, whatever you choose,
I can guarantee
it's going to come with
a big ol' hug free of charge.